transition toute trouvée puisque c'est
le gros dossier du jour à savoir le
business juteux de cyril sur m6 on a
remarqué que les animateurs généralement
font des mails carrière d'animateur
parce que ces lignes est un excellent
d'animateur il fait ça très bien il a eu
et son émission guetter un carton
banques ont fait moi qui savais comment
kevin vatant tous un peu sur tous en
cuisine sans accusation puisque ça
marche est très très très bien et on
s'est intéressés donc à son business est
vrai que selignac en chiffres eh ben
c'est assez impressionnant c'est en 2013
fortune estimée à quatre millions cinq
d'euros en 2020 forte mais 6 et 10
millions 250 mille euros par saison la
télévision ça c'est bon c'est bien c'est
pas mal non
cent cinquante d'entre eux c'est très
bien il fait travailler les gens dont je
vais très bien voilà un sua quatre
restaurants 5 bat ici un chocolatier à
mon avis les cartes restaurant on peut
faire une petite croix pour l'instant
parce qu'elles servent à les fermer
j'ai livré un scénario mais 43 livres
publiés cinq des 26 millions d'euros
c'est quand même pas mal c'est alors est
ce que vous êtes choqués où nous parlons
il ya dix ans encore qui vont dire oui
au nom non je suis choquée juste par
l'opposition avec les candidats de du
meilleur pâtissier qui eux ne sont pas
du tout payer c'est à dire que les
apprentis pâtissiers ne touche pas un
centime c'est le producteur qui l'a dit
sous prétexte qu'ils sont dédommagés
parce qu'ils sont logés blanchis nourris
donc c'est ça qui me choque un petit peu
plus et mercotte aussi la différence de
salaire elle l'a dit elle l'a confié
dans le parisien en disant qu' elle
gagnait pas si bien les avis que la maxi
ruffier c est ce qu est ce que vous êtes
étonnés à windsor la question je referme
la question est ce que vous êtes étonné
a dit qu'il ya un tel business autour de
ceignac parce que c'est vrai qu'on moi
je ne pensais pas du tout qu'il avait
fait autant avant d'être tant mieux pour
lui encore une fois il a créé une marque
cyril c'est sa scierie ville à créer une
marque et il est malin il est bon moment
il est dynamique il est jeune nancy
cyril c'est pas un mot qui porte chance
au lait
cyril lignac cyril hanouna
mais les héros c'est vachement bien que
c'est vachement bien c'est mérité et
puis c'est ce que vous créez une
embauche il fait il fait beau c'est des
gens et tant mieux c'est bien il faut de
la réussite sur bravo bravo syrie ligne
alors là oui oui mais c'est surtout je
rejoins c'est ce qu'elle dit jean pascal
c'est comme c'est comme aussi stéphane
plaza il laurent dieu star sérieuse il
mérite il mérite largement sa série
minya qu'on l'a connue depuis bien
longtemps maintenant il a tort voilà
donc à 6 mois maintenant donc moi je me
rappelle de lui gt gt by law moi je
dormais rgo mais ils méritent ils
méritent n'oublions pas qu'elle a quand
même aussi pris des risques il faut pas
oublier que quand vous ouvrez une
pâtisserie et chocolaterie ou un
restaurant vous n'êtes pas sûr que ça
peut marcher sera plus très bien pas
marché du tout il aurait pu perdre
énormément d'argent et c'est donc c'est
aussi un hors jeu prend lyricis la sq
étaient vers le principe de l'émission
qui l'a fait online et bien voilà je la
regrette et je pense qu'il a gagné ou
une partie de son restaurant à peu près
bien
il y en a plein car il y en a plusieurs
mais après il réussit en vrai
businessman dans l'âme parce que vous
savez la formule gourmand croquant en
fait il ne l'a jamais dit c'est des
guignols qui ont créé cette formule et
il a déposé la marque ensuite donc déjà
on sent voyez quand même qu'il y avait
une bombe en croquant guignols en fait
ils ont créé il me l'a jamais mis de
bâtons ont créé la réussite avec la
réussite vous avez selignac en
restauration c'est la blague
stéphane plaza pardon dans l'immobilier
ce sont des marques c'est un business
et aujourd'hui comme vous l'imaginez 150
employés aujourd'hui qu'il chine qui le
nourrit chaque jour surtout aujourd'hui
par la voix lui chapeau à lui qu'on
arrête roseraie de s'offusquer pour des
chiche et celle là où elle qu'on peut
sauver c'est qu'il y ait un relais de
croissance via la télévision n'ont même
pas d'accord parce que stéphane plaza il
a quand même ajouté son nom et c'est une
marque maintenant commercial
mais c'est la télévision c'est qu'ils
ont au fil pleinement de cette
exposition qui va au quotidien donc
c'est là où il peut y avoir un mélange
de jean cyril lignac c'est pas le cas je
veux dire ça ça fait pas cyril lignac
pâtisserie cyril lignac
maintenant il profite de sa notoriété la
force d'âme 6 elle est là c'est que il
crée d'abord des marques et derrière
c'est ce qu'on appelle la ville
pacification et c'est le modèle de m6
c'est 50 50 50 % de revenus
publicitaires 50% les diversifications
ce qu'ils essayent de faire tf1 depuis
maintenant cinq six dix ans il n'y
arrive pas forcément créer des marques
m6 y arriver ils sont nés comme ça et
bravo elle est ce qui explique aussi le
gros coup dans la tête qu'après le
business plan de m6 avec justement le
business s'était auto puisque pour le
coup les agents de dino médias tout ça
les restaurants de cinq ans mais c'est
vrai c'est je rejoins je rejoins
totalement ce que je voulais dire selon
vous quelle est la nôtre où les autres
animateurs qui pourrait exploiter leurs
noms et l'ordre et leur savoir faire
pour en faire un business
je fais très bien français comme lui
c'était un c'était un trois étoiles
avant même de faire de l'à beaucoup
aidée aussi
norbert bas je pense que la sallaz il
est aussi je pense
la télé comme comme à l'aller dire oui
c'est vrai norbert norbert bertrand et
oui mais je trouve que par rapport à
jour chargé imbert thubaneau rebelles il
a gardé ses racines il a gardé cette
sympathie cette popularité illimité avec
les gens de la vraie cuisine de la vraie
bonne bouffe et moi je les rencontrais
ya pas longtemps j'ai été surprise du
personnage qui a développé aussi des
business qui est vraiment qui sans ce
soutien qui fait un carton
mais j'ai aimé cette fête personnes
alors que cyril lignac j'avais rencontré
une fois il avait été très hautain très
froid très un émoi ce oui c'est vrai et
ce côté cuisinier pour moi c'est du nord
vers sait pas quels sont vos points
salignac un mois j'ai trouvé très
hautain il m'avait prise d'eau comme
jamais il ta prise d'eau n'ont cessé
[Rires]
oui oui pas votre cd non non non je dis
on ne veut pas savoir
oui christopher oui non moi je vois là
faut pas être envieux et il aurait
jamais réussi s'il n'avait pas de talent
c'est une vraie sind vrai succès story à
la française ça donne ça donne beaucoup
d'espoir à des jeunes qui veulent
aujourd'hui se réaliser donc bravo à lui
il a eu raison de surfer sur son talent
mais vous êtes resté longtemps
savard et j'en passe
je connais bon c'est comme ça on se dit
tout c'est un col
elle est obligée de l'émission caisse
calories tape risio mai à caen
convaincre que c'est extrêmement discret
sur sa vie privée
arrêté il a fait tous les palmes et
magazines people sont encore dépendants
et moi je vais vous dire je n'ai jamais
boudé sa jeune et je n'ai jamais goûté
ça chagrine mais pour moi ce sera
restera à vie mon héros parce qu'il est
sorti avec ce fils idéal je vous dire ça
ça vaut du fond donc rencontre était
vide
non il ya un truc que je comprends pas
daniel latulippe n'est pas choqué mais
la semaine a envoyé par jour oui pour
les stars américaines tu t'étais au fut
salée s'est dit je ne me sens pas ton
discours permet bien sûr je vais
t'expliquer c'est totalement différent
là c'est ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
il a il a fait travailler sans effet
travailler 150 personnes il a à ses api
créé un empire et il réalise en relais
bio ses terres allouées la disponibilité
de personnes
excusez-moi esclave non mais elle n'est
celle n'emploie pas elle quelqu'un alors
ça n'a rien à voir ça va dans salignac
aussi une partie mais il a créé des
emplois et c'est un ancien chef
d'entreprise qui a été aidé par la
milice avait déçu c'est normal c'est la
fin des missions et les frais non bâti
les grosses stars de la musique du
cinéma fogo ces personnes c'est
exactement pareil commence à parler de
second que vous prenez un acteur une
star de cinéma alors que plusieurs
américains james bond chaussée se et ce
saut mais à sa façon oui c'est le chef
d'orchestre du jardin d'un bambin d'un
projet artistique sachant qu'elles sont
soit plus que tous les autres ça n'a
rien à voir avec un chef d'entreprise
pour moi la différence est que lui l'un
c'est à peine si ça parce qu'ils sont
beurre sans nous rouler dans la farine
voilà qui a fait son beurre sans nous
les apparaît en revanche il a bientôt
puisque d'une part être quel autre
question sur deux s'est mis à prix kevin
vatant n'achète pas de questions je
pourrais vous avez une question sera
posée pascal oui non alors vous voulez
savoir en fait mais je suis même un peu
choqué alors c'est 5 millions 6 d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires pour les
coordonnées gilbert non mais je
m'attendais mais marc sont derrière un
petit peu plus parce que c'était en
amendes pour les stylos sinon c'est une
estimation parce que alors aussi un oui
très important tous les chiffres qu'on a
donné là sont une estimation parce que
ça peut être plus ça ne choque pas parce
que c'est vrai que ce qui fait c'est pas
la scène empire puis réussi et c'est
normal et c'est mérité mais je vois je
m'attendais quand même à un peu plus
quand même jusqu'ici ils fortune estimée
à 10 millions d'euros
le droit de penser beta mais n'attendez
plus il est écrit je suis un agitateur
lui
oui la question je me pose c'est quel
animateur à importe le plus à m6
d'argent c'est ça le la langue alors
qu'en fait c'est des bizarreries vous
l'expliquer unique n'est pas dit que ce
sont des business parallèle entre les
restaurants les agences mais à bruz
d'autres alliés du numérique a beaucoup
de choses d'exercice expliqué me koubbi
je voulais non mais je leur ai expliqué
ce que je voulais vous dire c'est un
moyen extraordinaire pour m6 de
fidéliser ses animateurs merci a
quasiment pas de mercato
m6 vers les autres parce que l'inric ou
platzer bien sûr à leurs intérêts de
mende a laissé le modèle m6 c'est 50%
des revenus publicitaires comme les
autres chaînes de télévision et 50%
la diversification c'est un groupe qui
est née sur ce qu'on appelle la
diversification c'est à dire qu'ils
prennent un animateur
ils font des boîtes de jeu il fonde et y
crée des marques auprès des produits
dérivés autour et c'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que m6 en règle générale
quand il ya une crise publicitaire s'en
sort un peu mieux que les autres puisque
ils ont quand même la diversification
qui le ramène beaucoup d'argent parce
qu'on parle du succès financier de cyril
lignac ou de stéphane plaza il profite
aussi très fortement quand même à m6 et
sa radio maintenant du même groupe si
tous les deux
pardon tous les deux sont à la radio il
présente ses recettes maintenant sur rtl
et pareil pour stéphane plaza qui fait
le jeu de julien courbet le matin est en
train de faire une élection pourrait
donc si je vous suis pour vous il ya un
plagiat ou lignac sont pas transférables
pour moi ça jamais qui est le prochain à
votre avis c'est un petit frenchy parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya plagiat nord si ça
je ne suis pas madame irma
non mais
c'est le paysage centres aims to get an
ils sont en train tout doucement bien
c'est julien courbet qui a réussi
brillamment son parcours jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant qui est arrivé à redonner à
rendez-vous
tard dimanche soir sur m6 ils sont en
train de lutter plus en plus entre rtl
et joey synergie entre rtl et de m6 je
pense qu'ils ont créé quelque chose avec
julien peut-être le défenseur des
consommateurs
merci heureusement qu'il ya merci
beaucoup pour ses éclats six tours
jumelles